Monsieur Bernard delcro sénateur du
groupe de l'Union sont triste
vous avez six minutes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre cher collègue faire
des prévisions budgétaires pour 2023
dans un contexte européen et mondial
aussi fragile et incertain relevez
évidemment d'un exercice extrêmement
difficile auquel nous devons malgré tout
nous livrer un responsabilité pour notre
groupe ce premier budget du quinquennat
doit marquer l'État vers deux objectifs
le redressement de nos finances
publiques et je pense que nous
partageons tous cet objectif réduire nos
déficits et contenir notre endettement
mais aussi mais aussi deuxième objectif
consacrer les moyens qui sont
nécessaires pour répondre aux besoins du
pays dans des domaines aussi cruciaux
que la santé l'éducation la justice la
sécurité notre défense ou encore la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
alors ces objectifs sont-ils
conciliables nous pensons que oui que
c'est possible mais pour y parvenir nous
considérons que si nous devons bien
évidemment mieux maîtriser nos dépenses
est une nécessité une coupe drastique et
globale dans les budgets n'est pas la
solution à l'heure ou des besoins
croissants se font jour et concernant
les emplois publics un sujet qui revient
régulièrement
des allègements sont bien sûr possible
dans certains secteurs la démonstration
a d'ailleurs été faite avec la
réorganisation des services de Bercy
notamment grâce aux opportunités
ouvertes par la dématérialisation et le
prélèvement à la source mais ces
allègements doivent avant tout permettre
des glissements vers des secteurs dans
lesquels des moyennes supplémentaires
sont indispensables et je ne suis
personnellement pas favorable à des
coupes à l'aveugle dans nos emplois
publics dans une seule approche
comptable c'est pourquoi pour réduire
notre déficit et contenir notre dette
notre groupe considère que nous devons
aussi agir sur un autre levier
l'accroissement des rentrées fiscales
dans les caisses de l'État un levier à
travers lequel l'État doit d'ailleurs
jouer pleinement son rôle de régulateur
nous ferons donc des propositions
concrètes pour accroître les recettes de
l'État comme les a détaillés Sylvie
vermeiller avec la contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
profits le report de la suppression de
la CVAE la suppression de plusieurs
niches fiscales que proposera notre
collègue Michel Calvet ou encore une
lutte renforcée contre la fraude fiscale
chère à Nathalie Goulet concernant les
collectivités locales permettez-moi tout
d'abord de rappeler une nouvelle fois le
rôle essentiel qu'elle joue dans tous
les territoires de France pour soutenir
le tissu économique et l'emploi pour
assurer les services au plus proche des
habitants pour garantir la cohésion
sociale pour réussir aussi le pari de la
transition écologique cette réalité doit
guider nos choix et éclairer nos
décisions sur la DGF nous approuvons
l'orientation prise par le gouvernement
d'augmenter les moyens qui lui sont
consacrés en ciblant les les plus
fragiles
mais nous savons bien que derrière les
moyennes souvent mises en avant se
cachent des disparités très fortes aussi
pour mieux tenir compte de cette réalité
nous proposerons de porter la hausse de
la DGF de 320 millions à 500 millions
d'euros
concernant la dotation aux communes pour
la protection de la biodiversité qui
reconnaît enfin le rôle essentiel des
territoires ruraux dans la protection de
l'environnement je veux saluer les
avancées obtenues nous proposerons une
amélioration complémentaire peu coûteuse
mais qui effacerait une inégalité de
traitement
en matière d'investissement le maintien
de l'enveloppe DETR à son niveau actuel
la reconduction de la décile et le
nouveau fond vert doté de 2 milliards
d'euros viennent donc compléter
utilement le soutien aux investissements
des collectivités locales nous proposons
également de réintégrer les dépenses
d'aménagement de terrain dans les
ligibilité au FCTVA de laisser au
territoire le choix de répartir
librement la taxe d'aménagement comme
nous l'avons voté hier en loi de finance
rectificative et de décorer les taux de
certaines taxes locales trois mesures
très attendues par les cellules locaux
et nous regrettons monsieur le
rapporteur général que hier nous ayons
fait le choix de priver les
collectivités de la récupération du
FCTVA pour les aménagements de terrain
je veux enfin évoquer les mesures que
vous proposez afin de protéger les
collectivités les ménages et les
entreprises face à l'explosion du coup
de l'énergie le plafonnement à 15% de la
hausse des tarifs réglementés en faveur
des ménages et des petites collectivités
et l'amortisseur électricité en faveur
des collectivités et des entreprises
nous semblent de dispositifs bien ciblés
et bien calibré nous les soutenons
il en va différemment pour le troisième
outil que vous proposez le fil est
sécuritaire en faveur des collectivités
si l'objectif de ce filet de sécurité le
bon ces modalités de mise en oeuvre nous
paraissent trop complexes et par
conséquent son effectivité incertaine
nous vous proposerons donc les redéfinir
à partir de critères simplifiés et
clarifier monsieur le ministre nouvelle
fois notre groupe aborde l'examen de ce
projet de budget de manière positive
avec la volonté de trouver avec le
gouvernement les meilleures solutions
pour notre pays et pour nos territoires
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues à la demande du
ministre ou suspend donc quelques
minutes et nous reprenons dans quelques
minutes merci chers collègues